jörg völkerling du weißt du was es in
dem prozess in dem fall ein neues gibt
am tag nach dem ersten prozesstag
meldete sich am landgericht würzburg
eine zeugin mit einer neuen wirklich
wegweisenden aussage sie sagt jetzt putz
nach theresa stokes nach diesem
schrecklichen unfällen angestrichen
aber der beifahrer auf einer
geburtstagsfeier gestanden er habe
niklas h den fahrer angestachelt theresa
um zu fahren
die worte sollen gelautet haben hobby
und das passt jetzt wiederum zu einer
beobachtung die teresas freund nico an
diesem abend gemacht hat am 22 april
er sagte kurz bevor seine freundin von
dem vw golf erfasst wurde habe er noch
ein schlenker nach rechts gemacht
das bedeutet für die staatsanwaltschaft
anstiftung zum mord das heißt der
beifahrer ist gestern abend festgenommen
worden er wurde heute dem haftrichter
vorgeführt der haftbefehl erließ
wie jetzt für die es für niklas arbeiter
geht ist jetzt noch ungewiss zur stunde
waren noch frei heute nachmittag und ja
jetzt muss am nächsten verhandlungstag
kommende woche muss diese zeugin im
landgericht würzburg aussagen und das
könnte bedeuten dass dieser neu
aufgelegte prozess sehr schnell wieder
vorbei ist und dass dann eine
mordanklage gibt die dann zu einer
anderen kammer verhandelt werden muss
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren